hey guys this is ro
it's so exciting to see the
life-changing progress from our better
health challenge finalists
each of them found that incorporating
more movement was essential to their
success
but movement is essential for all of us
regardless if we're trying to lose
weight
or just make sure we continue to stay
healthy the best way to do that
you know what i'm going to say is
together so we're inviting all our
longevity family to join our fitness
challenge
beginning in october we'll be doing
movement and fitness challenges daily on
our facebook and instagram pages
these will be bite-sized movement
challenges for you to easily incorporate
into your day
if you're familiar with the 2190 rule
basically the idea is that it takes 21
days to establish a habit and 90 days to
establish lifelong change
we love that it matches up with our 94
live philosophy every day
together establish good movement habits
then keep going until they become
lifelong change
so join us watch for more info on this
and get ready to hit the ground running
or should i say
walking with us in october